Transcriber: Rama Ali
المدقّق: Arwa Mohamed
لماذا لم نسأل أنفسنا، أنه وبالرغم
من وجود كل وسائل الترفيه هذه
ورغم سعينا المستمر لكي
نكون سعداء في حياتنا
لماذا هناك أشخاص حزينة ومكتئبة
وربما تفكر في الانتحار؟
هذا بسبب أننا لا نتخلص من المشاعر السلبية
التي تكون ناتجة عن تعرضنا
لتجارب مؤلمة في حياتنا
مثل فقدان شخص عزيز،
أو التعرض لصعوبات في الحياة
أو التعرض للخذلان من شخص مقرب.
هذه المواقف تستمر في التراكم بداخلنا
ومن الممكن أن تتسبب لك بإحساس
بأنك غير قادر على التحرك
وبأنه ليس هناك معنى لحياتك، وبأنك
لا تستطيع المضي دون هؤلاء الأشخاص
لكن، لا تقلق،
أنت لست وحيدًا.
أنا أيضًا، فرّقتني الحياة عن
أشخاص كنت أحبهم
ووضعتني في مواقف كهذه،
في كل مرة أتذكرها
تترك بداخلي أثرًا يؤلمني دائمًا.
وفي ذات يوم
قام شخص بترشيح كتاب لي
اسمه “Letting Go”، أو السماح بالرحيل
للدكتور ديفيد هوكينز
هذا الكتاب يشرح نظرية ال“Letting Go”
والتي معناها انقطاع مفاجئ لضغط داخلي
تشعر بعده بشعور الراحة،
والسعادة الممزوج بالحريّة
نعم، تشعر بشعور الراحة الممزوج بالحريّة
فهو يلخّص من خلال هذا الكتاب،
كيف يجب أن تتعامل مع مشاعرك
وكيفية التخلص من المشاعر السلبية،
حتى تتمكن من الوصول إلى شعور الراحة هذا.
لكن قبل أن أشرح لك كيفية التخلص من مشاعرك
سأشرح لك أولا كيف تفهم مشاعرك،
وتقرأ نفسك بشكل صحيح.
كلٌ منّا يتعامل مع مشاعره بثلاث طرق:
90 بالمئة من الأشخاص الحاضرين هنا
يفضلون الطريقة الأولى
وأنا كنت أوّلكم أيضاً،
وهي إنكار أن الشخص حزين
أن أقول أنني لست حزين وأنني بخير
هذه الطريقة تسمى القمع أو الكبت،
هنا أنت تخفي مشاعرك ولا تواجهها أبدًا
أمر آخر صدمني عند قراءة الكتاب،
في حين كان من الشائع قول
أنه عندما تتكلم عمّا يؤلمك، فإنك ستتخطاه
و قول عبّر عن مشاعرك لكي تنساها،
تبيّن أن كل هذا غير صحيح، فقد أثبتت
الأبحاث والدراسات أنك عندما تتكلم
عن شعورك المؤلم ، فإنك بذلك تعمقه بداخلك
ومن الممكن أن تنقل هذه التجربة السيئة
إلى الشخص الذي أمامك، فيشعر بالشعور السلبي
رغم أنه لم يمر بأي تجربة سلبية
هذه الطريقة تسمى بالتعبير،
أما الطريقة الثالثة فهي الهروب
وهي تكون باستخدام ملهيات، كأن تلجأ إلى
الكحول والإدمان والمخدرات
أو من الممكن أن يكون شيء بسيط،
كأن تقول، سأقوم بحضور فيلم، وسأصبح بخير
أو أن تقول، سأقوم بسماع بعض الأغاني
فأخرج من المزاج السيء وأكون بخير
الطرق الثلاثة هذه،
تخزن المشاعر السلبية بداخلنا
وهناك بعض الأشخاص الذين لايستطيعون
الخروج من هذه المشاعر السلبيّة
لأننا على مدار حياتنا تعرضنا لمواقف،
زرعت بداخلنا هذا الخوف
هذه المواقف كانت كفيلة
بأنها تجعلنا في كل مرة نتعرض بها لموقف
جديد، نخرج الشعور القديم نفسه ونشعر به.
تخيلوا معي، شخص تعود على الفراق
والخذلان منذ صغره
منذ عمر مبكر،
لم يكن الطفل المفضل عند أهله،
وبين أصدقائه لم يكن أحد يختاره،
لو دخل إلى مقابلة عمل يتم رفضه
ماذا سيكون شعوره في هذه اللحظة؟
أو لو مثلًا  وقع في الحب وكان هذا الحب
من طرفٍ واحد.
كيف ستكون مشاعره في هذه اللحظة؟
من المؤكد أنه سيشعر بأنه مدمّر أو مرفوض
أو أنه غير قادر على الاستمرار في الحياة،
أو أن يقرر أن  يبقى لوحده إلى الأبد.
لكن هل رد فعله هذا هو ردّ على
هذا الموقف البسيط الذي تعرض له؟
الإجابة هي لا،
فهذا الشخص على مدار حياته
وجد نفسه في الكثير من المواقف ،
التي عمقت هذا الإحساس بداخله
وكان هذا الموقف الصغير
بمثابة الشرارة التي أخرجت هذا الإحساس،
عقله الباطن اختار الأشخاص الخطأ،
الذين لا ذنب لهم فيما حدث
فعكس عليهم الشعور الكامن بداخله،
وجعلهم يلعبون أدوار ليست أدوارهم
يقول الدكتور  ديفيد هوكينز: أن الشعور
هو مشتق تراكمي من الأفكار، وهذا معناه
أن الأفكار ليست  ما يؤلمنا،
وإنما المشاعر المختبئة وراء هذه الأفكار.
ولكي يوضح لنا هذا الأمر،
وضع مقياس سمّاه مقياس الوعي،
والذي يقسم الأفكار إلى ثلاث مناطق;
أولها: المنطقة السلبيّة وتتدرّج من
العار إلى الأسى
هذه المنطقة تمثل أول ما تشعر به
عندما تتعرض لموقفٍ مؤلم
بعدها المنطقة الانتقاليّة;
وتمثل رد الفعل على المشاعر السلبية،
من الخوف وصولاً إلى الاستعداد
وبعدها المنطقة الإيجابية،
وهذا ما نسعى للوصول إليه
بعد أي موقف سلبي أو مؤلم نتعرض له.
تخيلوا معي التالي، لكي نفهم
هذا الموضوع وتدرٌّج المشاعر
ضع في ذهنك مثلاً فكرة أنك خائف
من أن يتخلى عنك أصدقاؤك، أو أشخاص معينة
وأقنع دماغك أنهم تخلّوا عنك بالفعل
ما الذي ستشعر به؟ أول شيء ستشعر به
هو مشاعر حزن لما حدث
هذا ما تمثله المنطقة السلبية
بعدها، لو كنت أنت في هذا الموقف
ماذا سيكون رد فعلك لو أنهم تخلوا عنك ؟
من الممكن أن تشعر بالخوف،
الخوف مما حدث أو من كيفية مواجهته
أو من الممكن أن تشعر بالشجاعة وأن
تمضي قدمًا فلا وقت للأحزان
وبعدها من الممكن أن تكون قد
تحرّرت من هذا الشعور
إلى أن تصل إلى المنطقة الإيجابية، وستشعر
أنه يجب أن تكون متقبّلًا للوضع وراضٍ عنه
وأن تمضي في حياتك، ومن غير المقبول
أن تبقى منشغلاً بهؤلاء الأشخاص
من الضروري أن تمضي قدماً،
ربما ستقول لي حسنًا لكن هذا موقف خياليّ
لكن ماذا لو حدث لي مثل هذا
الموقف في الواقع، ماذا ينبغي أن أفعل؟
سأقول لك الآن دور نظرية ال“Letting Go”
هذه النظرية تقول، أنه عليك أن
تعيش الشعور مثلما هو
أن تتقبّله، ألّا تهرب منه، ألّا تحاول
أن تواجهه أو تخاف منه
لا تحاول أن تتعامل معه بمنطقية، بمعنى
لا تسأل نفسك لما حدث هذا معي أنا بالتحديد
تجاهل أي أفكار تأتي في ذهنك
بخصوص هذا الشعور
يعني، أرفض فكرة أن تتهرب منه،
وقل: عليّ أن أواجه نفسي، أن أختلي مع نفسي
كل يوم، و أفكر أنه ليس
من الصحيح أن أبقى هكذا
من المفروض أن أتخطى الموضوع،
لا تقيد نفسك بوقت معين،
أي لا تقل لنفسك، أنه بحلول الغد، يجب
أن أكون قد تخلّصت من كل هذه المشاعر
كلا، اتركها تأخذ كل الوقت
اللازم لكي تتخلص منها تماماً
لا تسمح لأحد أن يخبرك بأنك تبالغ،
أو بأنك تعطي الموضوع أكبر من حجمه،
أنت فقط من يمكنه تحديد ذلك.
في حال كان سبب هذه
المشاعر لا يزال موجوداً
ستقوم بما يسمى معالجة للماضي،
معالجة الماضي هي أن تفكر بذلك الشعور
ماهي نتائجه الجيدة والسيئة
عليك في ذاك الوقت
حسنًا
هل تعلمت الدرس ؟
هل جعلك هذا الموقف أنضج ؟
هل الموقف الذي حصل لك
يستحق أن تضيّع المستقبل
في التفكير في أشياء هي أصلًا من الماضي ؟
كلا.
ركز على مشاعرك واعترف بها.
خصص وقتًا للتفكير، لو كنت مثلاً غير متفرغ،
حاول ولو لمرة في الأسبوع،
أن تجلس لساعة مع نفسك .
تفكر في أي طاقة سلبية شعرت بها
على مدار الأسبوع،
جعلتك غير قادر على التعامل معها،
أو المضي قدماً
حتى تصل إلى مرحلة التسليم.
التسليم هو أن تشعر أنك أسقطت
كل العبء والشعور الملقى عليك
أن تشعر أنك حرّ.
في حياتنا، كان هناك مشاعر كثيرة،
تخلصنا منها بشكل غير واعي
سابقاً كانت تؤلمنا، لكن الآن
من الممكن ألّا نذكرها حتى
على العكس، هناك مشاعر أخرى،
نحن لم نتخلص منها
هي تنتظر فقط الشرارة لكي تظهر،
فهي مازالت موجودة لأننا لم نواجهها أصلًا،
دورك الآن أن تختار الشعور، وتواجهه
اعرف أنك مهما وقعت ستنهض من جديد
مثلما وقعت الأن للتو هنا بجانب السُلُّم،
ونهضت لأصعد وأقدم هذا الحديث، إنه أمر عادي
كل واحد منّا سيقع وينهض، وسيكمل
طريقه بدون الأشخاص الذين تخّلوا عنه،
وسوف يتخطى كل هذا الشعور،
لأنه لا يمكنك البدء بالفصل الثاني،
اذا استمريت بقراءة الفصل السابق
هذا كل شيء
شكرًا.
(تصفيق) (تشجيع)